well we've been making games for who
over 30 years over 30 yeah that's
showing all right so yeah we started
back in the 80s originally sort of from
81 with a zx81 our brother bought it and
we just found under the TV instead of
playing with it aged about 12 or 13 I
guess yeah I really got kind of it well
that was when computers all came with
sort of keyboards and not great games so
you kind of end up like making them
yourself whereas nowadays it's all
consoles stick a disc in and off you go
and you wouldn't know where to start
where we have our real success was on
this little tiny of rubber we keyboard
its spectrum with a 40mm there was a
cheap 16 K yeah but nobody out there
okay a Walking 48 and yeah it was a case
of trying to make games on this 8-bit
computer is that limitation a good thing
yeah I actually like limitations in some
ways it was a puzzle in how to get the
biggest game or adventure working on the
very limited memory and the thing that I
used to remember particularly was they
couldn't move many graphics around the
screen so you literally had to say okay
I can move little sprites around the
screen and I'm only gonna be out of
cover like eight or so sprites on the
screen what game could I come up with
which like well you had to design the
games around the technical ability of
the computer so you had to look at what
it could do and how it would work and
how much memory and then design your
game according to it whereas as computer
technologies got better you design your
game first and the computer has to fit
it and how did you work together then on
this you've got one computers two of you
initially initially we would just share
a one single computer and when one was
actually using the computer typing in
code the other one will be working out
code on paper to be perfect eyes it's
actually a really good thing because we
used to plan things out really well
because the computers were so slow and
so basic with just text editors that
it's actually really difficult to write
the code and it was all assembly
language so it was really really
codified but because you couldn't have
computer time because he had it you'd
actually you'd sort of sit down plan it
out you'd you're scrappy little diagram
diagrams if you remember that from your
computer studies and you try work it all
out and you'd actually write it all down
and then when you've got the computer
time you would just type in what you'd
worked out on paper we've got all of
these like hand-drawn notes but it was
amazing that it really gets your
thoughts in place and how do you think
we missed it as soon as we had money to
buy two computers we just summon a
computer what text editor on its might a
few lines press compiler doesn't work it
crashes and actually you didn't sit down
and take stock and plan things
so would you debug it on the paper as
welder there are many times we had a
really hard I think the logic definitely
and the overall structure but maybe not
debug I don't know there were times
where there's really really nasty bugs
and you'd literally just put in two out
and you get a pen and you'd be following
it rained and rained and trying to work
out why because the computers and those
we coded things like a spectrum on a TV
with it
RF aerial okay now I was wearing glasses
for years and years and it was because
of things like that right if you are so
blurred if you actually go back and look
at the display and think that we were
sitting on first off lots of hours 15 16
17 hours a day looking at those well
yeah when we weren't working the
planning we were in front of the TV not
monitor TV I mean the signals just
terrible and it's amazing that we could
even read the text but you only have a
few characters across because I have big
chunky text because the resolution of
graphics was 320 by 240 bit level from
your 4k monitors may so initially
started with a family TV so there's NX
81 the dragon 32 they were family TV but
then the next computer we bought was an
Amstrad we didn't bring them on Saturday
but it came with its own monitor but
it's the air computer W but it doesn't
check anything away wait you'll find
this from our YouTube channel we talk a
lot about his loft so during the 80s and
early 90s it was just the two of us
making games we then set up a company
initially called Interactive Studios
that was because the consoles came along
and we'd be a team yeah you needed sort
of for proper artists then yeah
resolution graphics had gone up so we
decided to set up a company Interactive
Studios initially that was then renamed
in 1990 blitz game studios that company
grew of doing lots of contracts with big
publishers like your electric arts and
THQ and his knees were only Microsoft
all the big publishers and that company
grew to over 235 people and that went on
through until 2013 when unfortunately
times changing digital downloads
free-to-play models and everything all
changed and 40 blade stop trading so we
set up another company and that's called
radiant worlds and we're developing a
game it's a massively multiplayer online
game chance of changing all of that
they're great things to learn online I
think every student should have a play
with these things that Andrew decided to
learn scratch and write a full game in
an evening yeah cuz his son totally
couldn't write make a decent game well
my son had been asked to watch but it
was about I don't know heaven or 12 or
something at school and they'd come home
and their homework was write a little
game on scratch and it was supposed to
like Paul or something and he was busy
doing it and he was doing okay ish but
he made some coin about like well you
could never are at a proper game and I
was looking at it going that's yeah I
think you could I would try to think of
the things that you couldn't do because
these things were pretty flippin basic
what they didn't do much but we wrote
some big games on them so I looked at
this scratch and divided by itself it
was revised incredibly powerful and it
was just the case of seeing what and how
it would work and I was looking at it
and thinking well it wouldn't do 3d
graphics clearly but you can motor 2d
yeah you could do anything to D in any
of the 8-bit games and I saw us had any
8-bit game like what a lot of pac-man
there's like yeah you could write
pac-man easily and after we went bad I
decided to write pac-man on scratch ok
by breakfast time I was ready yeah it's
got I think it was something like
400,000 years today it's at a few years
possibly inspired well no actually just
completely copied
the competition is vast I mean anybody
in the world can basically write a game
and it's very easy but on the other hand
there is a massive massive audience and
lots of really good tools and lots of
really good information about how to
write a game so it's different equation
but the opportunity is still there just
ask me like knotch
so but what you must do is actually do
something original and creative if you
wanted to get noticed so you will be
very able very easily able to make a
game and if you're interested in games
you absolutely should just get on and
make it don't talk about when I make a
game and I want to make a game just get
on a make a game the question is then
getting it promoted and seen by lots of
people
and that's actually tough these days
because there are so many games out
there on all the digital stores I
actually see a bigger danger when we got
into programming these things it was
partly because there were only two TV
channels rubbish music on audio
cassettes although we could listen to it
but we never have right we didn't really
read books as such and I don't know we
weren't really really bored and so
tinkering on a computer was what we like
to do kids can't get bored now they just
physically can pretty much every kid I
know has a computer a smartphone a
console access to Netflix YouTube
Optifine which is brilliant but if you
just spend your time being entertained
and you're just a consumer somebody's
got to sit down and go I want to be
brilliant at music I want to be
brilliant to art or whatever and spend
hours and hours that it takes to learn
so we just dedicated our time to do this
stuff partly through boredom and that is
not really an option anymore kids don't
get bored so I actually think that's
sort of made you put a taken major
hurdle yeah absolutely and you know the
one prop we don't have as a copy of the
book if somebody can hand us a copy the
book
we are expecting more guests than this
this does sound terribly like an answer
but I have to point out that we don't
actually take any money from this
in fact the contribution of the
publisher Chris Wilkins would have give
it to us is that being donated to
special effects which do all the work
with disabled kids who want to play
video games yeah they do some brilliant
stuff I mean the things that I did with
eye tracking those up some games that I
like talking about it even felt like
Stephen Hawking could play video games
because they've got it so that you can
just sort of like control computer with
your eyes which is very cool but they
built into games like yes you can
probably build into text messaging as
well could that be useful but now I was
playing a kart racing game with my
lights which is very cool so they do
some really good work so we've given our
money to them just really nice to solve
be able to solve record so much stuff in
the book that just lives in my life I
mean this is just at one example green
world pokey on the NES so yeah it's just
a box finally mile off I'm just covered
going and it must go through
there's just well that's the original
sort of city diagram some letters back
and forwards code there's this is the
source code that we have to recompile
from at one point we were going to be
calling it blitz which is kind of funny
that we came back to that Lane really
called our company blitz in the end and
then just kind of working out some sort
of notes of how we layout characters and
memory basically it was all the disks
and paperwork they were across the desk
halfway through you'd like where do I
clear this to get another bottle clear
it into the box file and then as the
game sort of finishes you just clear the
desk and just clear it all into the box
file whatever is still on the table that
didn't go in the bin so unfortunately
the same thing a block but the story the
story's a little bit more a bit longer a
bit more complicated but it was
developed for the NES Codemasters
were running into various issues with
Nintendo and publishing games on the NES
and unfortunately this one was decided
not to be released by them which was a
great shame but there's a little bit of
longer story
it is but the stories in here of course
that green we had 46 games and half of
them were number one bestsellers I mean
just lay the statistic like that the
book has got so much content in its
gonna be quite difficult for people in
the future to interview us and say can
you tell me something new that isn't in
the book